What the [MUTED] is your problem?
Oh, wait, I know this one.
You are.
If I ask you to do a press conference,
do the [MUTED] press conference.
OK, I'm sorry.
I didn't realize it was a big deal.
So you just didn't do it?
Is that the plan for the rest of your life?
You're just going to walk away from everything the second
it isn't fun or easy?
What do you want, Roy?
Hm, what do you really want?
I just want to be left alone.
Oh, [MUTED] Roy, you want way more than that.
You're just so convinced that you don't deserve anything good
in your life that you'd rather eat a bowl of [MUTED] soup,
and then complain about the portions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Get out of your own way, man, because this whole woe
is me thing you've got going on is just [MUTED] ponderous.
Is that all?
Yeah, that's it for now.